previously on raft
land hoes Lando whoa hey armor
yes backpack
really
oh
I don't see any Blowfish we have not
going out far enough I need oxygen
I'm in a cave do you have flippers yet
nope
this guy doesn't even have flippers I am
making the organization wall I love that
there's a shark in my cave whoa you can
put him on the wall why are both of the
waters down here empty
Wade come on I have never come on in the
history of us doing this got in the
water hold it back up he's never failed
to be heard him first I will murder you
why don't you go get some Blowfish I
think we've harvested everything under
the water here that's to be gone we need
to cut down any trees or anything or we
don't need that stuff anymore I'm going
yeah he's going you know what I mean you
feel me
you know oh leaving world oh the
darkness has consumed me oh I'm in rooms
now
[Music]
oh I found a way out of the back rooms
oh curtains the nightmares or whatever
is in there
yeah the bad the spooky man
what the legs that guy yeah the legs
out where the leg one yeah that's a real
oh I lost some soup I still cannot join
you I should probably just restart my
everything Maybe mayhaps
indubitably
heard him indubilee if you guys want
soup to plant soup and dumpling yeah
dumplings yeah oh God I could go for a
dumpling well not that kind of super Zoo
I've dumpled in a long time I'm here for
some dumplings let me seeing it like
that is he saying it weird am I crazy I
feel like he was saying it weird
dumplings I don't know you it sounded
like he was saying it weird he was
saying dumplings
you can swim underwater with your bowl
of soup in hand and it will be perfectly
fine it's a thick soup that hangs
together it really hangs it even
continues to steam normally one might
say cloying in a way very cloying the
soup it does cloy you're right like a
exploring on what was I doing and also
we got the trees
uh I think we were ready to leave then I
think we're done here aren't we yeah
we've been hanging around for this one
for quite a while so I suppose we could
Mosey
we've got a engine now shall we
uh yes do we have a heading
um you know what uh
uh uh yeah we were heading in the right
direction yeah now we're super boned uh
don't give me a heading uh yeah one
moment
I cannot just go around the other side
of the island kind of go that way that
way it does not uh mean no that way that
way ish ish don't forget about the ish
whoa Mark what's up I'm a wizard uh uh I
think your feet are being eroded into
dust
only slowly okay nice new skin thanks
how many toes you got Johnny I don't
know why don't you come on them
I count nine and two thumb toes
wait that'd be too many eight and two
thumb toes I better double count on me
and never shoot I lost one and I had him
put an extra thumb on
is this the correct way for the heading
I don't know probably not wow you head
your head up your ass
uh where's the raw food chest for these
grills uh
suddenly I recall oh okay oh wait you
know what I don't have all the meat in
existence oh that's a thing that didn't
save I hope it's in here it's not we
lost the whole stack of need oh damn it
I blame Wade for this Our Fair
yeah the title of my Memoir harsh but
unfair would be a good comedy special
name I'll just find the heading on my
own oh you needed the heading it was on
the other side of the island-ish
yeah okay thanks
very ishally yes we're pretty good what
kind of meat was it was it like the the
steaks looking thing yeah ish wrapped
straight ahead
shark on the right side of the boat
whatever that's called starboard
letters that's how I remember oh that's
handy way to know I never would have
known a little sad my Starburst joke
didn't land but that's fine oh what say
it again
isn't that a kind of candy ah is that
Starburst Bob everyone laugh in the
comments everyone please laugh oh you
guys should get me
all right we're dead on the headache
thanks for your help wraps straight
ahead
are there any blueprints or anything
that can get off these rafts that would
be useful anymore probably uh yeah
probably I don't know do you want to
move more towards Starburst a little bit
so we can get it not really okay
there's no shark right
is there a shark is it a shark he's
right behind there he is behind you I'll
Dodge I'll Dodge watch this uh too early
he doesn't seem to be buying your dodges
oh God no it's sinking God I hope you
have a lot of Health
bro don't worry I think you might have
lost the shark is definitely not right
behind you it's right oh man
that's what the flippies are all about
everybody did you get anything good what
oh right I got stuff uh yeah worth it
yep
hey why did this make what do we need
most right now materialized uh
[Laughter]
[Music]
uh okay we need wood we could use more
scraps take this I made it for you
I think I think oh thank you
Mark do you have a place where you're
putting uh taters are you farming taters
anywhere yeah I'm kind of splitting in
between you know the bioreactor and uh
soups but we seem to be good on soup so
I'm gonna start shoving in the
bioreactor okay cool hey do you know
what button you need to press to hide
your ping and FPS
I what I don't know what button did you
press to turn it on that'd be my guess
that's a great question I don't know the
answer to man The the engine really
changes this whole game can I just say
that yeah quite fast uh I'm in charge of
the boat now and it just sort of goes
the right direction no matter what
happens and it's really great and I love
it
you know what I mean you know what I
mean yes yes we all know what you mean I
guess I'm just gonna crash
I'm fine it's fine I'm fine yeah good
good excellent well we should be I think
I see the very edge of the next big big
island
friendly just ahead of us I think I very
faintly see it you know what I have a I
have a I'm gonna do a thing remember how
I said I wasn't gonna put the steering
thing way up high yes yeah [ __ ] that are
you putting it whereby I like to be a
captain I like to be a tall Captain all
right that's good uh why are you saying
hi I'm trying to figure out how to get
rid of this thing oh turn it off yeah
how the button to turn it off button
yeah
yeah what is that uh probably whatever
you push to turn it on off fun yeah
exactly is there a huddle I would love
for there to be a
problem you know wait wait
I got you a person
thank you I won't say a word don't tell
Bob
the whole like there's a lot of
underhanded healings
did it for you wait remember
always remember always remember never
forget what yeah
what are we doing uh we're trying to
help wait for how to turn this thing off
that's ruining his whole [ __ ]
recovery
uh
[ __ ] recording goddamn [ __ ] uh
maybe F1 or something or
yeah I mean it's probably an f and f key
yeah try one of the F's oh well I
screenshotted I left everything
try try one of the letters
fried them all
right oh Q's not the right one that
throws thing
's eating us guys look at this enormous
Island over here
holy crap what is that
doing stuff to our butts and our butts
can take it our butts are tough Tonka
tough that one's already not following
our storage conventions they're so
obvious
I'm sorry it wasn't me though oh hey
it's the o button you just have to press
it many times apparently hey guys I
figured we're back hey all right
right hey girl look at Island Wade look
land oh
hey Bob I'm gonna give you Bob are you
gonna stick on the boat or are you gonna
go out on the island I want to hang out
on the boat I'm gonna hang out all right
cool I'm gonna go out because uh we got
we're waiting now we're equipped for it
you know what I mean you know I mean
we're equipped for it yeah I believe you
I definitely believe you you get the
implications of that you know what we're
saying to you yeah I heard your I heard
you say it yeah all right good just
wanted to be clear okay Crystal
I'm gonna get some soup I'm gonna get
some soup and we're gonna go to the
island I don't know why you're saying it
like that I kind of hated some extra
soup would be good
yeah load up on super I yeah done with
the soup uh I'll even take one with me
hear the Scarecrow away maybe scare the
bird ah the bird's scared the scare bird
crow the bird you know what I'm saying
if you scare the Scarecrow away I'm
nervous because it's not supposed to be
alive
anyway
see all right we can charge our
batteries boys whoa
all right I'm going it's a battery
charger part but it's not like a
physical thing I grabbed I think it's
just for this island I'm gonna head
Inland I'll leave all these trailers to
you uh Wade uh good luck thank you I'll
head in I'm doing really important stuff
guys good
scientific Journal classified really
important stuff good I would hope so
like
crucially important if I'm honest great
that's that's good
yeah so you know just be you know aware
I guess okay cool thanks man so you're
welcome really
thank you and you're welcome too
what am I welcome for what did you do
for me how important is the stuff that
you're doing that's the question ah man
not as not as wow the water's empty
again [ __ ] shocker I don't know how I
literally refilled it just like a few
minutes ago I might have dunked my head
in swirled it around and then splashed
it over myself in a ceremony of leaving
that goddamn boat and literally could
not be more empty than it is excellent
teamwork everybody yes yes and then I
said God help anyone stuck on this God
forsaken place
you know I was you know I was is there a
shark attack in the boat what was that
noise it's not water wouldn't you like
to know yes that's why I asked usually
yeah well I thought so
yes yeah right uh-huh and yeah and I
don't have a retort
wow what the hell hit me armor old age I
don't know I don't know man all right
welcome back all right sorry I had to
are you trying to solve the mysteries of
the well yeah I got it I was just
dangling some dangles are you out some
dangles dude I'm angling I'm dangling
can you watch that dangle what Bob does
anyone have a gun I don't know I gotta I
got a whole bird situation I'm honest
yeah uh wait is that going in the right
spot ow oh hey I was supposed to be
watching something do it again
uh yes it's filling up the well all
right cool
no patience for science I can grab it
now do you want me to grab it at the zip
line oh yeah grab it grab it you know oh
wow can I be real with you for a minute
what's up yes things are not going great
guys gotta be honest how so there's you
a boat and a shark what could possibly
be there's also a bird dropping actual
bombs on my head and I don't like it
that's what hit me I see stay under the
roof I'm working on that the bird seems
to not give two shits about the roof if
I'm 100 it doesn't give a [ __ ] about the
roof that's not that's not very
bird-like I know that's that's pretty
bird-like or not birth like whatever you
said is probably right but yeah but you
know it's uh it's fine all right very
dark also just like you know just oh the
bird's attacking me go back to Bob no
he's fine where he is I think yeah I'm
okay with his arrangement I deserve this
hey it's a bird whoa it just grabbed
some I almost got a I almost was able to
Spirit and end its problem once and for
all but I I didn't oh dude and excellent
problem please God sorry guys I missed
it well I didn't even swing so it's not
so much that I missed it so I didn't
fail but I didn't succeed but also you
didn't not fail you're right I gotta
look on the bright side don't do your
best do the best of somebody better do
the better's best I like that that's
that's ins that's inspirational thank
you I stole it for a horrible monster
creature in Supernatural could have
sworn it was my statement oh hey I got a
stone Arrow can we make bows oh Bob Bo
the bird that was my idea Baba listen to
my wisdom listen to the wisdom of my
words
gotta make a bow okay you gotta Bowl the
bird oh okay oh there's bees here I'm
making important stuff here guys
like and such as I know how it happens
uh hot you know you ever just you guys
have a captain's Hut because I have a
cat I don't have a captain's Hut no I
thought we lived in a democracy
what
democracy it's like a democracy but on
water
okay can I get the Latin root
oh God
lagomocracia
uh-huh it means democracy but on water
can you use it in a sentence yeah I
thought this was a law of democracy
hmm
interesting interesting
this bird does not like me I mean who
does really
it's time for honesty corner with Bob
yeah who does I want to find out who
does be honest with me who does let us
know in the comments if you like Mark
Sailing as one the Roth towns of
Indonesia we'll check at the end of this
episode 70 people commented it okay
I wouldn't count on a lot Mark I would I
would really you know oh I just need a
few dedicated excitations you know I
didn't have any you know that's the
funny thing
by one of our reporters about their
living conditions so interesting you
seem pretty confident about this Mark oh
my God guys there's interior design
options and I didn't even know that what
ah wouldn't you like to know I that's
why I went what my interrogative was
very pointed interrac of my nuts
did we get us you got me
yeah buddy it hurt it really hurt man I
could do we have flashlights I would
really love any style kind of world do
you think we live in yeah one that used
to be a civilization oh use your night
vision
what's that uh
for night vision F4 yeah I feel like I
did that to us once already today
whenever steam went down
all right you know the steam from our
engine
yeah no we ran out of steam everybody
yeah yeah yeah were you about to break
RP
are you about to no hey there's a turkey
here there's a turkey we could catch a
turkey
We need oh we should yeah we need to go
swimming we need to look for uh
little fish yeah
so get on that you're doing I'm going to
continue doing God's work Fellers thank
you all right I need a I need a bigger
house than I originally thought I mean
don't worry about it
there we go that's how we're doing it
now I don't know man this sounds awfully
not helpful I'm just building a
Captain's Quarter so that I can
effectively Captain the ship
my God I hate this letter
oh man oof am I right guys oof all right
this this roof is really going to take
some engineering I gotta be honest
I'm not confident in my Roofing uh it
feels
freaking bird I hear it it does sound
very bird-like it's extremely bird-esque
where's the mayor uh next to the ketchup
in the fridge
oh man this I think that signals the end
of our career boys
oh we're faked
myself for that joke more than you hate
me for it I don't think so
hey did you find another zipline part
how ziplining are we
uh if I did you'd have it I'm one making
my way up still we need three
here's something oh God
vote on board that was not a zip line I
have I got my way back to the boat and
give Bob all the stuff to put in chests
yeah I'm pretty full up as well but we
got all these zip lineables
yeah no definitely Zip Zip take your
time I don't want you to I don't want
you to get back until it's done you know
yeah
in this Southern Sea
well I've made it to the top of yes
excellent my high school career
yes yes
despite all of these trailers
it's only stuff
I mean stuff's good I like stuff
I got some bees some biofuel
mango Nana recipes
there's a goat hopefully by the time we
get back down there mark Bob will have
gotten all the Blowfish in the water
yeah I know I'm I'm harvesting ever
everything we're gonna need hey does
anybody have any scrap per chance never
mind we're good ah Daddy's good we're
good what
I found a dodo bird
I may have used all of the wood that we
had but it's for a good purpose and I
think everyone will agree I somehow
doubt it can't wait there we go he
wouldn't lie I would not lie he wouldn't
he wouldn't lie uh what a what a joy oh
boy
die bird I missed all right I'm ready
for I'm ready for you to return to the
ship whenever that's good because I am
very full of [ __ ]
I'm also full I've hit the bird twice
but I ran out of rocks hmm that sounds
very frustrating my friend I have one
Arrow one
one Arrow one bow one chance this is it
die I hit it wow I can't believe I hit
it I have more than one Arrow as well
man what a man look at this man look at
me man look at me man
look at me look at my man look at my man
now back oh I killed it oh I killed it
oh you're dead oh oh yeah nice oh my God
God it's dead it's freaking dead oh my
God it's freaking dead hello it's dead
it's dead it's dead okay we need more uh
fuel what a zip line not fuel Zip Line
Parts
we need more zipline gas can you guys
get some Zippy gas hey Bob I'm back I'm
home how's it going we're good pretty
good but at night
you can't really see all the work I've
done but it's a lot
I believe you
but it's it's not you'll have to really
it's in a specific spot
okay it's like a like a scavenger hunt
for the work and it'll be really hard
for you to find it
wow is it this house you can't come in
it's my house house would you like to
visit my house yes sure come in enter oh
thank you oh let me just stop it okay
well I was gonna okay that I've really
prepared that for myself but yes you
could have it I guess that's sorry I was
just walking in the joint join me oh
okay oh yes excellent you guys okay you
guys need yeah we're just chilling we're
just chilling yeah chilling relaxing yes
I see what might have happened to our
entire stash of wood one of them well we
didn't have very much if I'm honest
really but it's fine yeah I know it's
got you know it'll be great it's a nice
hole in the floor right here we can just
drop down right to the
ah that doesn't sound very good it's not
like that hole in the floor what do you
oh no everything's great there's nothing
to worry about he doesn't he doesn't
know I'm a jokester I love jokes tell it
that was it that was the wow two of
these crop plots are fully empty whoops
Mark were you hoping to have all these
potatoes that you planted be potatoes
and not just nothing I mean it would
have been nice I expected that given
that I planted them and then they grow
well then they did and that's fine
good anyway anyone finds some Zip Line
Parts nope I need to go hunting for
Blowfish hmm
it's probably fine
well I think I think I've explored just
about every every domicile I could I
haven't found anything were you in the
water were you uh above the water I was
in the the trailer park here how they
got so many trailer parks here I have no
idea but
they did
well you can put the mark in the trailer
park but you can't get them out because
he's stuck
um that's what they say that's what I've
said
I don't know where these other zipline
Parts would be I've explored pretty much
everywhere
oh God I fell I'm good I'm okay though
chill and chill
oh I see oh right it's all the water
puzzles it's not actually anything in
the things it's all the way oh we need
to go underwater for this one I forgot
about that one oh yeah isn't there like
a that thing that you've also just
reminded me exists yeah and then there's
so many Blowfish down below there Wade
right right yeah I know I need to go get
them
get them get a water bottle get an air
blow thing
get an air thing
he means
yeah that one probably that's what I
meant you guys gave me sport wood so I
can keep doing my craps I'm coming back
to the boat I just gotta remember where
it is over by the big duck okay big dog
big dog big doc we might need some of
that wood to keep food going yeah don't
didn't mark just make a whole shitload
of food I thought I did maybe maybe I
didn't you know now that my memory is
faulty
I don't think I did where did I get head
oh when did you get that one oh yeah
anyway I got I don't know apparently I
did at some point uh where do I put the
wood
in one of the uh the ones that are with
crafting stuff in them or whatever our
Grafton junk is uh put some wood in
there with the metal and over here gonna
get some rocks or
uh where do you want glass at do you
want glasses with the oars
uh no because that's already processed
oh man got a lot of biofuel though there
was tons of biofuel uh what about bees
uh there's a jar of bees already
somewhere there's a jar of these in the
top left one up here oh this is mine you
have to ask to come in here
I don't
okay I'm okay
it's you can if you want I have a really
Comfy Couch no no no no I'm good there's
a bath
oh yeah did you find our wood Source
marked
no I have no idea
ignorance to it if you will ignorant I
sure you don't want to check it out did
you did you want me to oh yeah yeah of
course oh okay well yeah okay cool okay
come in come on in oh thanks
so yeah I we're uh we've got the couch
gonna have a nice kind of a Chase thing
on the end here and then there's a table
for you know if you
if you don't if you want to do that or
something what's that uh but also
there's a uh the the bath how do you
like the bath
I mean there's what it's really cool man
um water there's water everywhere around
this horse oh wow that's a fire hazard
and the and then the flag right for
Captain stuff right inside where the
wind blows I got some windows it
probably blows the same in here probably
yeah
no it's real cool man
thanks I just it's great I'm thinking
you know what you your comment about the
flag was on point though I think you're
right yeah I'm gonna just go ahead and
fix that that'll that'll that'll make
yourself so much better don't worry God
man I'm fine all right I find just my
feelings are hurt really but that's okay
oh man yeah you'll be more oh look at
where the flag is now that's much better
ah super cool Wade did you get your
oxygen bottle I you didn't I didn't no
I've not had any chance to do that I've
been what's up what's up what's up
what's up what's up you didn't you
didn't look at it what's up man hey it's
a great couch that's such a cool couch
oh boy okay okay well I think thanks for
looking huh
yeah it's better without it yeah I think
the flag really really didn't do
anything for you so I'm glad but it's
over here look where the flag is now
yeah oh oh see now because it solved the
problem ah
laughs
I need four rope and four rope I got you
buddy here you go wham can you not leave
my door open next time hmm
what's that what'd you say you left uh
you left the door open I had to close
luckily I was leaving too because it was
time to no okay I'll get it don't worry
hey no need to ask guys got it no door
open
the opposite really is what I wanted all
right wait are you ready for your
undersea Adventure I'm making flippers
then I will be uh we're out of Vine goo
though I have some right here here vangu
on the floor one one vine on the floor
we just got cook it up
yeah well we have a bunch of uncooked
vines in the Box I did that I I did that
but I successfully marked this stuff on
yeah no it's great organization it's
fantastic I have flippers on Mark did I
flipper right yeah you got flippers on
yeah cool and a bottle is that how bad
mine look yes yeah that's how you look
the same yeah
I was walking around with like with like
cool looking flippers because the art
was kind of cool well okay I just need a
battery how do you know wait there was a
dead one there was a dead battery
so we recharge it no you don't even need
to charge it maybe I don't know I feel
like you might need charge in the
battery I wonder if you can craft with
one that's not charged though I'm
thinking I'm thinking yes it's fully
charged
right here
uh good luck
where am I going where are you
underwater
oh look at your school here right here
go for it have fun somewhere around here
there's a place yeah it might be on the
other side of the island